نحن في وسط مدينه هاتاي حيث الدمار في كل
مكان والبنيات المدمره ومن هم تحت الانقاض
والبحث جار عنهم هنالك من ياتي الى هنا
وينتظر فقط ان يحصل على جثمين من يخصه من
ذويه الذين يتواجدون تحت الانقاض وهنا
العم فقد علم بان ابنه وزوجه ابنه حفيده
قد رحلوا ولكنه ينتظر حتى يحصل على
جثمينهم ما الذي
حدثني لحرمه ابني مقشعه اما امر شيلها
ابني وكانتي
والده يعني وين موجودين الان هون قريب منا
نبري من هون تعال نمشي انا واياك عشان
تحكيلي تفرجيني كيف كيف متى تلقيت خبر
وفاته انت تاكدت انهم توفوا هزه
التلفون من اسطنبول قال القرميط طير ابوها
عن الابرت
مسكره بعدها ما حملني قلبي ولدت الثاني
عمل لي تلفون قال لي يا بيي خيي هو تحت
الجسم لا تقول قلت له اختك هيك ما تقول
قال والله يا بيي انا حملت حالي جاي خيي
وام بنته يعني انتم تاكدتوا منه انهم
رحلوا توفوا توفوا توفوا معهد ما نقدر
نشيلهم ما حدا يقرب لكن انت بدك جثامينهم
تنتظر جتامين
اشرح لنا وين المبنى اللي هم موجودين فيه
الحلق والله انا بنتي يوم الحد العصر
الاحد عملت لي التلفون يا جدي يا ددا ايش
تعمل قلت لها انا كتير كيس انت ايش قال يا
جدي انا يوم فلان الي ميلاد بيوم الخلق
عيد ميلادها عيد ميلاد بدك تجيني قلت بدي
اجيكي بشغله ايش قال يا دادا ايش يا جدي
شو هالشغله قلت لها ما بقول لك
يوم الميلادك ايش بتجيب لي قلت له اما انا
محضر لحلق في دانا قلت تعطيها هو
الحلق وببكي وهلق شات تمورطه حط خارجياتها
جواتها وعب فيها للولد قشدها وامها نايمه
نصها باينه اما امشي تحت الجسر والغطه
حيشات وما قدرت تقرب ايش بدي اعمل انا قمر
نعزيكم نعزيكم بما رحم
العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي هاتاي